其他人：来看一下来学习大家都是人才说话又好听很又意思
Others: Just here to learn, everyone is so talented and eloquent, it's really interesting.
Shure: 我给你拿衣服去
Shure: I'll get you some clothes.
其他人：然后我觉得这个实验好像也很有趣
Others: And I think this experiment is very interesting too.
其他人：然后他也感觉他态度很好
Others: And he seems to have a good attitude.
其他人：然后我们一起来看下怎么样
Others: Let's take a look together.
其他人：然后到处都是摄像头
Others: There are cameras everywhere.
其他人：感觉
Others: Feels like.
其他人：好像有种在录那个楚门的世界的感觉
Others: Feels like we're filming The Truman Show.
其他人：有一种感觉
Others: There's a feeling.
其他人：我希望大家今天玩的开心热闹一些哦
Others: I hope everyone has fun today and make it lively!
Shure: 10个币子
Shure: 10 coins
Shure: 来小度你
Shure: Come on, let's do it
Shure: you deserve it
Shure: 好的下一波从8个币子开始
Shure: Okay, the next round starts with 8 coins
Shure: OK
Shure: 完了市场要崩了哈哈
Shure: Oh no, the market's gonna crash, haha
其他人：通货膨胀了是吧
Others: Inflation, right?
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
其他人：大家好我是来自   大学的
其他人：我是可欣的室友我是    大学
其他人：然后我就是挨的特别明显的挨人
Others: And I'm someone who stands out clearly as an outsider
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：就是在在我高中第一次进宿舍的时候
Others: It was like this, the first time I entered the dorm in high school
其他人：这个宿舍三个月对我说的第一句话
Others: This dorm said the first sentence to me after three months
其他人：我一直以为你是一个特别高冷的人
Others: I always thought you were a really aloof person
其他人：因为你从来都不说话的
Others: Because you never spoke
其他人： 后来发现其实并不是这样子
Others: Later I found out it wasn't like that at all
其他人： 谢谢大家
Others: Thank you everyone
Shure: 然后刚刚说的是几个必字来着
Shure: So just now, how many coins was it again?
Shure: OK
Shure: 那我们下一个环节啊
Shure: Now, onto our next segment
Shure: 不是呸
Shure: No, wait
Shure: 下下一下一个介绍
Shure: Onto the next introduction
Shure: 5个必字开始
Shure: Starting with 5 coins
Shure: 5
Shure: 4
Shure: 三
Shure: 3
Shure: 3个了
Shure: 3 left
Shure: 别别别炸了两个
Shure: No, no, no, it's down to 2
Shure: 一个了然后后面呢
Shure: 1 left, then after that
Shure: 就可就没有了
Shure: There's nothing more
Shure: 我们后面的拍品非常的精彩的
Shure: Our next items are really exciting
Shure: 我们提前看过大家的这些
Shure: We've reviewed everyone's items in advance
Shure: 这些派品都非非常的非常的棒
Shure: These items are truly, truly amazing
Shure: 真的真的没有在自告奋勇来
Shure: I'm not even exaggerating, really
Shure: 来介绍一下的吗
Shure: Anyone want to introduce themselves?
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay
Shure: 那6个
Shure: Then 6 coins
Shure: 6个不能再多了啊
Shure: 6 coins, no more than that
Shure: 只有6个
Shure: Only 6
Shure: 再给大家最后3秒钟考虑时间
Shure: I'll give everyone the last 3 seconds to consider.
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Shure: 我们这波就直接进行下一环节了啊
Shure: We'll move directly to the next segment.
Shure: 3 21
Shure: 3, 2, 1.
Shure: 好的那我们结束introduction环节
Shure: Okay, we're done with the introduction segment.
Jake: 我们花了整整5分钟
Jake: We spent a whole 5 minutes on that.
Alice:可以
Alice: That's fine.
Shure: okay
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 那我们就进行呃
Shure: Then we'll move on to the, uh...
Shure: gas的那个拍卖环节吧
Shure: the gas auction segment.
Shure: 然后大家看
Shure: Everyone take a look,
Shure: 一眼自己手头的币子都有多少
Shure: at how many coins you have on hand.
Shure: 现在谁的
Shure: Now, whose...
Shure: 要不谁的币子少谁先上来拍
Shure: Whoever has the fewest coins should come up first to bid.
Shure: 呵呵呵
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 给你给你
Shure: Here you go.
Shure: 先赚点钱吧
Shure: Go make some money first.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
其他人：随身带了一点很好玩的东西来的
Others: I brought a little fun thing with me.
其他人：就是等会我去拿一下手机
Others: Just wait, I'll go get my phone.
其他人：这是这是一个钥匙扣
Others: This is, this is a keychain.
其他人：但它其实
Others: But actually,
其他人：里面是那个胶片黑白卷奇怪的图片
Others: inside, it's a black and white film with strange pictures.
其他人：是我自己去拍的
Others: I took them myself.
其他人：然后今天带了5个
Others: And today, I brought five of them.
其他人：它是基本上都是风景
Others: They're mostly landscapes.
其他人：应该是有四张大海
Others: There should be four of the ocean.
其他人：然后有一张是个楼房
Others: And one of a building.
其他人：是的
Others: Yes.
其他人：就是很神奇的是因为它是黑白卷
Others: The amazing thing is that because it's black and white film,
其他人：所以正常这么看是看不到的
Others: you can't see it normally.
其他人：需要用光对
Others: You need to use light, right.
其他人：哪边是正面
Others: Which side is the front?
其他人：这边是正面
Others: This side is the front.
其他人：需要去用光照一下
Others: You need to shine a light on it.
其他人：或许能看到他那个里面的形状
Others: Maybe then you can see the shapes inside.
其他人：还蛮有意思的
Others: It's quite interesting.
Alice: 老公给我买一个
Alice: Honey, buy me one.
其他人：就是相当于是你如果把它挂起来的话
Others: So, if you hang it up,
其他人：是有呃随身带的一小片
Others: it's like you have a small piece with you all the time.
其他人：属于自己的海的那种感觉
Others: It's that feeling of having your own sea.
其他人：而且你可以去
Others: And you can go...
其他人：就是通过对着手机的手电
Others: You have to use the flashlight on your phone...
其他人：或者对着阳光才能看到他
Others: Or shine it in the sunlight to see it.
其他人：蛮有意思
Others: Quite interesting.
其他人：我觉得蛮有意思的
Others: I think it's pretty interesting.
其他人：然后邱老师定个价吧
Others: So, Mr. Qiu, set a price.
Shure: 肖老师觉得这个每张呢就
Shure: What does Mr. Xiao think, per piece?
Shure: 一个起拍
Shure: Starting bid for one.
Shure: OK那就先一个起拍
Shure: Okay, let's start with one.
Shure: 好吧总共有5个
Shure: Alright, there are a total of five.
Shure: 那么第一张
Shure: So, the first one...
Shure:  第一张
Shure: The first one...
其他人：我给你打个光吧
Others: I'll shine some light for you.
Shure: 第一张是哪个
Shure: Which one is the first?
Shure: 是有一块
Shure: It's the one with a...
其他人：哦对
Others: Oh, right.
其他人：这五张其实不是同一个地方
Others: These five are actually not from the same place.
其他人：应该就是山东沿海的那几座城市
Others: They are from several cities along the coast of Shandong.
其他人：都拍过然后大概是从呃
Others: They were taken, roughly from...
其他人：20年到现在都是疫情时候拍的
Others: From 2020 until now, all taken during the pandemic.
Shure: 这张是一个有着
Shure: This one has a lot of rocks.
Shure: 很多礁石的一个海
Shure: It's a sea with many rocks.
Shure: 然后起牌下一
Shure: Starting bid is one.
其他人：一个
Others: One.
Shure: 一个两个
Shure: One, two...
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Shure: 两个一次
Shure: Two, once.
Shure: 两个两次
Shure: Two, twice.
Shure: 好我这边出3个
Shure: Alright, I'll bid three.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure: 3个一次
Shure: Three, once.
Shure: 三个两次啊
Shure: Three, twice.
Shure: 还有没有想要的
Shure: Anyone else interested?
Shure: 这个这个
Shure: This, this...
Shure: 非非常的beautiful
Shure: It's very beautiful.
Shure: 这个我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you...
Shure: 这是这五个里面比较不错的一个
Shure: This is one of the best among the five.
Shure: 三个三次
Shure: Three, three times.
Shure: 那就自产自销一下了
Shure: Alright, let's sell what we produce ourselves.
Shure: 好了
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 我我我收下了
Shure: I, I, I accept it.
Shure: 我真想要你
Shure: I really want you.
Shure: 嗯不一样
Shure: Hmm, different.
Shure: 给你发三个来
Shure: I'll send three to you.
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
其他人：我在是因为昨天他跟我讲
Others: I'm here because he told me yesterday.
其他人：然后找了一下
Others: Then I looked around.
其他人：没有别的可以
Others: Couldn't find anything else.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 那我们下一个
Shure: Let's move to the next one.
Shure: 这是什么
Shure: What is this?
Shure: 哦这是一个栏杆旁边的一个大海对
Shure: Oh, this is a big ocean beside a railing, right.
Shure: 也是起拍价1
Shure: Starting bid is 1.
其他人：一个
Others: One.
Shure: 一一个 2个
Shure: One, two.
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Shure: 两个一次
Shure: Two, once.
Shure: 两个两次
Shure: Two, twice.
其他人：三个
Others: Three.
Shure: 3个 3个一次
Shure: Three, three, once.
Shure: 三个两次
Shure: Three, twice.
Shure: 还有更高的吗
Shure: Any higher bids?
Shure: 三个三次落锤
Shure: Three, three times, sold.
Shure: 成交
Shure: Sold!
其他人：我太有钱了没办法
Others: I'm too rich, can't help it.
Shure: 哎呦完了
Shure: Oh no, it's over.
其他人：真让我赚到了
Others: I really made a profit.
Shure: 还有
Shure: There's more.
Shure: 还有一个啊
Shure: There's one more.
Shure: 第三个
Shure: The third one.
Shure: 第三个是一个
Shure: The third one is a...
Shure: 他有一个是楼
Shure: It has a building.
Shure: 其他的其实都是海哦
Shure: The rest are actually all seas.
其他人：这是这一张
Others: This one.
其他人：是青岛那个银泰帆船中心的船
Others: It's the yacht from the Qingdao Silver Sailboat Center.
Shure: 这是一个带有船的海
Shure: This is a sea with a boat.
Shure: 还有后背景是一个摩楼
Shure: And the background has a skyscraper.
Shure: 还有一些楼对
Shure: And some buildings too.
Shure: 起拍价一个一个两个
Shure: Starting bid is one, one, two.
其他人：一个
Others: One.
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Shure: 两个两个一次
Shure: Two, two once.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Shure: 两个两次哦
Shure: Two, two twice.
Shure: 他又三个
Shure: He has three.
Tasha: 这就是资产阶级
Tasha: This is the bourgeoisie.
Shure: 哎呦四个
Shure: Whoa, four.
其他人：哎呦四个
Others: Whoa, four.
Shure: 四个一次
Shure: Four once.
Shure: 四个两次
Shure: Four twice.
Shure: 4个三色so成交
Shure: Four, three, sold.
其他人：是不是应该让他们自己看一下是什么图案
Others: Shouldn't they take a look at the design themselves?
Shure: 然后大家拿到手可以其实用
Shure: And then everyone can actually use it.
其他人：我要增加一下我的拍卖资金
Others: I need to increase my auction funds.
Lucia: 这个如果大家一会有人喜欢
Lucia: If someone likes it later,
Lucia: 也可以拍拍试试
Lucia: they can try bidding too.
Shure: 然后下一个
Shure: And next item.
Lucia: 就这个也
Lucia: This one too.
Lucia: 其实也是牙花
Lucia: It's actually a dental pattern.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 要不你拿着给大家展示一下
Shure: How about you hold it and show everyone?
Shure: 呃我拿着来
Shure: Uh, I'll hold it then.
Shure: 还是给大家展示一下吧
Shure: Let's show everyone.
Shure: 这个会看的更
Shure: This will be more...
其他人：你分清正反面反面照不出来的
Others: Make sure to distinguish the front from the back, the back won't show.
Shure: 更那什么一点对
Shure: More detailed, yes.
Shure: 给大家看一下
Shure: Let everyone take a look.
其他人：这是什么海吗
Others: What is this, the sea?
其他人：就是海面
Others: It's just the sea surface.
Shure: 对这是一个纯的海面
Shure: Yes, it's a pure sea surface.
其他人：有有有白手套吗
Others: Do we have white gloves?
其他人：给你上一套
Others: Here, put on a pair.
Shure: 然后还有啊
Shure: And there's more.
其他人：你这个不专业啊
Others: You're not professional.
Shure: 还有这个
Shure: There's also this.
Shure: 这个是一个楼的
Shure: This is a building.
Shure: 还有这两个
Shure: And these two.
Shure: 仅剩
Shure: Only these left.
其他人：选的都是没有人的那种
Others: They all chose places without people.
Shure: 对纯景的
Shure: Yeah, just the scenery.
其他人：因为有人的不太好
Others: Because places with people aren't that good.
Shure: 那就先先拍一个楼的吧好吧
Shure: Let's just shoot a building first, okay?
Shure: 这个楼的啊对
Shure: This building, yeah.
Shure: 一个大摩呃
Shure: It's a big... uh.
Shure: 也不算摩天吧
Shure: Not really a skyscraper.
Shure: 就是楼的一个井
Shure: It's just a building, you know.
Shure: 起拍价还是一个一个
Shure: Starting bid is still one, one...
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Shure: 两个
Shure: Two.
其他人：我想要海
Others: I want the sea.
Shure: 两个一次
Shure: Two, once.
其他人：哄抬一下特价啊
Others: Raise the price a bit.
其他人：三个
Others: Three.
Shure: 两个两次
Shure: Two, twice.
Shure: 你怎么都要买过来吗
Shure: Are you going to buy it all?
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 三个三个一次
Shure: Three, three, once.
其他人：这样就可以转拍了是吧
Others: So, now we can switch to auction, right?
Shure: 三个两次
Shure: Three, twice.
Shure: 露出了三三个三字
Shure: Three, three, three times.
Shure: 成交
Shure: Sold.
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Shure: 还有最后一个
Shure: There's one last one.
Shure: 这个是一个海的啊对
Shure: This is a sea, yeah.
Jake: 这怎么卖啊
Jake: How do you sell this?
Shure: 它是个海的
Shure: It's a sea.
Shure: 起拍价还是一个
Shure: Starting bid is one.
Shure: 一个
Shure: One.
Jake: 对呀怎么卖啊
Jake: Yeah, how do you sell it?
其他人：一个
Others: One.
Shure: 有人一个
Shure: Someone bid one.
Jake: 这要卖了
Jake: It's going to sell.
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Jake: 给给他钱吧
Jake: Give him the money.
Shure: 两个两个一次
Shure: Two, two, once.
其他人：她三个
Others: She bid three.
Shure: 你就不要不要跟gas抢了好吗
Shure: Don't, don't compete with gas, okay?
Jake:他也是是乱分的是吗
Jake: Was he randomly dividing it?
Shure: 2个两次
Shure: 2 twice
其他人：三个
Others: Three
Shure: 3个一次
Shure: 3 once
Jake: 试吃 一下
Jake: Try it
其他人：我也试吃一下回口比较好我一会儿帮你卖一下
Others: I'll try it too, it's better if I try it, I'll help you sell it later
Shure: 3个3个
Shure: 3, 3
Tasha: 好你就
Tasha: Okay, you just
Shure: 3个一次啊
Shure: 3 once, okay?
Jake: 这大老板都是这
Jake: This big boss is always
Tasha: 你就说出你的真实体验就行
Tasha: Just share your real experience
Shure: 三个两次
Shure: 3 twice
其他人：对我已经体验过了
Others: Yes, I've already experienced it
Shure: 没事咱们咱们可以说着
Shure: It's okay, we can talk about it
Shure: 四个四个一次
Shure: 4, 4 once
其他人：我还没叫
Others: I haven't called yet
其他人：行四个四个
Others: Okay, 4, 4
Shure: 四个两次
Shure: 4 twice
其他人：快点快点快点
Others: Hurry up, hurry up
Shure: 四个三次成交
Shure: 4, 3 times, deal
其他人：我要马上就要哈哈哈
Others: I want it right now, hahaha
其他人：太急迫了马上必须 马上把钱给我
Others: So urgent, give me the money right now
Shure: OK变成大富翁了
Shure: OK, turning into a millionaire
Shure: 富婆饿饿饭饭
Shure: Rich lady, hungry, hungry
Tasha: 要不是要不是替你还债了
Tasha: If it weren't for paying off your debts
Shure: 好的然后
Shure: Alright then
Shure: 现在谁手上的比较少一点
Shure: Now, who has the least in their hand?
其他人：我
Others: Me
Shure: 没到你的
Shure: Not you yet
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
其他人：8+8-，对12个
Others: 8+8-, yes, 12
Shure: 还有12个你呢
Shure: Still 12, what about you?
Shure: 6个
Shure: 6
Shure: 那黄导你先上来介绍一下你的拍品吧
Shure: Alright, Director Nicous, come up and introduce your auction item
Shure: 是中间这个相机吗
Shure: Is it this camera in the middle?
其他人：这玩意我看看
Others: Let me see this thing
Jake: 你要要这相机我们直接起飞
Jake: If you want this camera, we'll take off directly
Tasha: 好吧我我150个给你
Tasha: Alright, I'll give you 150 for it
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Jake: ego币
Jake: Ego coins
Shure: 哈来吧来吧
Shure: Haha, come on, come on
Shure: 黄岛黄岛先生
Shure: Mr. Huangdao, Mr. Huangdao
其他人： 不幸的问题是我今天还真没有什么拍品
Others: Unfortunately, I don't really have anything to auction today.
其他人： LUCIA 好像完全忘记跟我说这个事儿
Others: Lucia seems to have completely forgotten to tell me about this.
Lucia: 我好像没跟他说这个事这个样子了呢
Lucia: I think I forgot to tell him about this.
Lucia: 我因为我自己因为我自己忘了
Lucia: Because I, I just forgot myself.
Jake: 表演一下没关系的
Jake: It's okay to put on a little performance.
Shure: 还可以拍卖
Shure: We can still auction something.
其他人：拍卖一下才艺
Others: Auction off some talent.
Lucia: 你你你不是还有瓶水吗
Lucia: Don't you still have a bottle of water?
Lucia: 哈哈哈你不是还有瓶水吗
Lucia: Hahaha, don't you still have a bottle of water?
Jake: 哎好可以
Jake: Oh, okay, sure.
其他人：哦非常实用啊 实用道具
Others: Oh, very practical, a practical prop.
Jake: 完了和和市场接轨了现在
Jake: Now it's in line with the market.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh
Shure: 他这有一瓶我们这都没有的饮料
Shure: He has a drink that we don't even have here.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
其他人： 市场化道具
Others: Market-oriented prop.
Shure: 起拍价一个
Shure: Starting bid is one.
Shure: 没有没有那个
Shure: No, no, that...
Jake: 你后面的是不是
Jake: Is it the one behind you?
Shure: 我我靠
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure: 这也是你的
Shure: This is yours too?
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
Shure: 要不这样吧
Shure: How about this?
Shure: 那个给大家一起我们拍一组照片
Shure: We can take a group photo for everyone.
Shure: 然后
Shure: And then...
Lucia: 啊这个他擅长哈哈哈
Lucia: Ah, this is his specialty, hahaha.
Shure: 对来吧
Shure: Yeah, let's do it.
Shure: 也算是卖了一波艺
Shure: It's like selling a piece of art.
Shure: 怎么怎么拍
Shure: How should we take it?
Shure: 你可以定时下或者是怎么着
Shure: You can use a timer or something.
其他人：拍到了给他们拍一组写真
Others: Let's take a group photo for them.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Jake: 灯灯灭了
Jake: The light went out.
Katrina: 我吗
Katrina: Me?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 我在充啊
Katrina: I'm charging it.
其他人：嗯大家稍微聚拢一点吧
Others: Hmm, everyone gather a little closer.
Shure: 没摁
Shure: Didn't press it.
Jake: 可能是吧
Jake: Maybe.
Jake: 看一下吧
Jake: Let's take a look.
Jake: 没有就算了
Jake: If not, forget it.
Shure: 讲的我口干舌燥的
Shure: Talking so much has made my mouth dry.
其他人： 后面的背景会有些黑看见光了
Others: The background behind will be a bit dark, you can see the light.
其他人： 哦逆光
Others: Oh, backlit.
其他人： 还是到我们这边来
Others: Better come to our side.
其他人：我把饮料搁这
Others: I'll put the drink here.
Shure: 这两天吃胖了呢
Shure: Gained some weight these past two days.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Lucia: 都站到那个椅子的前面去吗还是
Lucia: Should we all stand in front of that chair or...
其他人：啊你往后推就行
Others: Ah, just push it back.
其他人： 那要不把椅子调个吧 因为前面有些坐着比较好
Others: Or maybe adjust the chair, it's more comfortable to sit in front.
Lucia: 哦对对要不然话大家可能就会
Lucia: Oh right, otherwise everyone might...
Shure: 来来来老板c位
Shure: Come on, boss, take the center spot.
Jake: 哼
Jake: Hmph.
Jake: 老板
Jake: Boss.
Lucia: 有人坐着有人
Lucia: Some are sitting, some...
Jake: 对我调不过去
Jake: Yeah, I can't adjust it.
Jake: 你帮我调
Jake: Help me adjust it.
Jake: 帮我调第一个
Jake: Help me adjust the first one.
其他人： 那我们往后
Others: Then we'll move back.
其他人：坐着还坐到这儿
Others: Sitting here or over there?
Lucia: 我站着 Gast风格
Lucia: I'll stand, Gast style.
Lucia: 啊对 Gast可以坐
Lucia: Yeah, Gast can sit.
其他人：它过来它全会在人脸上因为人正好是挡住的
Others: When it comes over, it will be on the face because the person is blocking it.
Shure: 纯白的是吗
Shure: All white, right?
Jake: 然后就是志愿者往后坐
Jake: Then the volunteers sit in the back.
Jake: Gaster先往前坐
Jake: Gaster, sit in the front.
Jake: Gaster往前坐
Shure: 纯黑的哦
Shure: All black, oh.
其他人：其实只有第二排能拍到 是吧
Others: Actually, only the second row can be filmed, right?
Shure: 弄个纯黑的
Shure: Make it all black.
Tasha: 然后空白的对
Tasha: Then blank, right.
Jake: 哦那前面三个椅子干掉是吧
Jake: Oh, the first three chairs in front, remove them, right?
Jake: 挪掉
Jake: Move them away.
Shure: 来吧老板站C位
Shure: Come on, boss, stand in the center spot.
其他人：这什么环节什么环节
Others: What's this segment, what's this segment?
Lucia: 拍照环节合影环节
Lucia: Photo session, group photo session.
Shure: 你本来最高
Shure: You were already the tallest.
Shure: 然后就还给自己加磅是吧
Shure: And then you still added weight to yourself, right?
Jake: 请坐请坐
Jake: Please sit, please sit.
Shure: 呀真好看
Shure: Wow, really good-looking.
Jake: 请坐请坐
Jake: Please sit, please sit.
Alice: 坐
Alice: Sit.
Lucia: 耶你怎么这么高
Lucia: Wow, why are you so tall?
其他人： 怎么都没人坐啊
Others: Why is no one sitting?
Jake: 请坐请坐
Jake: Please sit, please sit.
Jake: 三位客人请坐
Jake: Three guests, please sit.
其他人：坐前面坐着
Others: Sit in the front.
其他人：后面有人站着
Others: Someone is standing at the back.
其他人：不觉得像这种家族照片
Others: Doesn't it feel like a family photo?
其他人：像那个什么
Others: Like what?
Shure: 老板老板老板来来来
Shure: Boss, boss, boss, come here.
Jake: 老板老板老板
Jake: Boss, boss, boss.
Shure: 老板站中间老板站中间
Shure: Boss, stand in the middle, boss, stand in the middle.
Jake: 站后面站旁边就好了
Jake: Stand at the back or side, it's fine.
其他人：你也得过来
Others: You also need to come over.
Lucia: 福星你这个相机有自动那个什么吗
Lucia: Fuxing, does your camera have an automatic function?
Lucia: 呃是可以的
Lucia: Uh, yes, it does.
Jake: 有三脚架
Jake: There's a tripod.
Lucia: 但是有三脚架
Lucia: But there's a tripod.
Jake: 有三脚架
Jake: There's a tripod.
Jake: 对我们三脚架l多了
Jake: Yes, we have plenty of tripods.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哎现在可以哦
Lucia: Hey, now it's okay.
Lucia: 不可以你是没那个啥了
Lucia: No, it's not okay, you don't have that thing.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
其他人：我刚刚在说家族照
Others: I was just talking about a family photo.
其他人：专业设备
Others: Professional equipment.
其他人：这三脚架一直没用上
Others: This tripod hasn't been used.
其他人：没用上哈哈就等你呢
Others: Haven't used it, haha, just waiting for you.
Shure: 哈哈哈就等你呢
Shure: Hahaha, just waiting for you.
Jake: 对就等你了
Jake: Yes, just waiting for you.
Shure: 我们算到了其实
Shure: We actually calculated that.
其他人：那狗的CP呢
Others: What about the dog's partner?
Alice: 我我我我狗的老老婆呢
Alice: What about my dog's old wife?
Lucia: 那里
Lucia: Over there.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake: 在这蹲俩是吧
Jake: Squatting here, right?
Lucia: 哎可以让他们加进来可以吗
Lucia: Hey, can we let them join in?
Jake: 猜不到吧
Jake: You didn't expect that, right?
Shure: 让他俩让他俩也进来
Shure: Let them join in too.
Lucia: 他俩在前面哎
Lucia: They're in front, hey.
其他人： 对让他俩前东西吧
Others: Yeah, let them go up front.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake: 这边
Jake: Over here.
Lucia: 要不咱俩换一下那个啥
Lucia: How about we switch that thing?
Lucia: 因为
Lucia: Because...
Lucia: 这样可以在
Lucia: This way we can...
其他人：你想过来就来吧
Others: If you want to come over, just come over.
Alice:没事
Alice: It's fine.
其他人：你别太矜持了你
Others: Don't be too shy.
Lucia: 哈哈你在这边
Lucia: Haha, you stay over here.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice: 我打不着你了是吧
Alice: I can't reach you now, right?
Lucia: 然后我们可以这样
Lucia: And then we can do this...
其他人：哈哈一对新人
Others: Haha, a new couple.
Lucia: 一对新人一对新
Lucia: A new couple, a new...
Lucia: 狗哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Dog, hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 你的狗戴花花
Lucia: Your dog is wearing flowers.
Shure: 你把上面那个gopro给写下去对
Shure: You should write down that GoPro up there.
Lucia: 你的狗才是新娘
Lucia: Your dog is the bride.
Lucia: 哈哈哈你的狗笑你
Lucia: Hahaha, your dog is laughing at you.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：说的我脸红了
Others: I'm blushing now.
Lucia: 哈哈哈说的我发现你特别妖娆
Lucia: Haha, you look so charming.
Alice: 感谢你特别邀请
Alice: Thank you for the special invitation.
其他人：确实这个看起来比较像新郎
Others: Indeed, this one looks more like the groom.
其他人：可以吻新娘
Others: You may kiss the bride.
其他人：我是不是问过你几点的车
Other: Didn't I ask you what time the train is?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈救命
Lucia: Hahaha, help!
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：我应该问过吧
Other: I should have asked, right?
Shure: 你问过我给你发过
Shure: You asked, and I sent you the info.
其他人：几点
Other: What time?
Shure: 我也忘了
Shure: I forgot too.
Shure: 下午三四点钟差不多
Shure: Around 3 or 4 in the afternoon, I think.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: Why?
其他人：没事问问一下
Other: Just asking.
Jake: 后面没
Jake: Is there anything else?
Shure: 然后自己玩去是吗嗯对啊
Shure: Then you're going to play by yourself, right? Yeah.
Alice: 祸乱后宫罪不容诛
Alice: Causing chaos in the harem is unforgivable.
Jake:是一页吗
Jake: Is it a page?
Shure: 就就放这些吧
Shure: Just put these here.
Shure: 那个放白的那个有点就是照到脸上了
Shure: The white one is kind of shining on the face.
Jake:OK行行行
Jake: OK, fine.
Lucia: 咱这甚至还有补光灯呢
Lucia: We even have a fill light here.
Lucia: 不需哈哈
Lucia: No need, haha.
其他人：可以啊哎呦
Other: Sure, wow.
其他人：补光灯啊
Other: A fill light, huh?
Jake: 补光灯要到前面的
Jake: The fill light should be in the front.
其他人：暂时不用了
Other: No need for now.
Jake: 还不用啊
Jake: Still no need?
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
其他人：啊对栗子刚刚给我发小猫她说看看猫吧
Other: Oh right, Lizi just sent me a picture of a kitten. She said, "Take a look at the cat."
Alice: 来吧
Alice: Come on.
其他人：呃好
Other: Uh, okay.
Jake: 雨萱拿
Jake: Yuxuan, take it.
Jake: 可以拿一个眼镜
Jake: You can take a pair of glasses.
Jake: 你可以不戴
Jake: You don't have to wear them.
Katrina: 那我假装戴上
Katrina: Then I'll pretend to wear them.
Jake: 你也可以
Jake: You can do that too.
其他人：好 10秒自拍模式啊
Other: Okay, 10-second selfie mode.
其他人：启动好
Other: Starting, okay.
Tasha: 其他人：
Tasha: Other:
Shure: 这一幕好像好似曾相识
Shure: This scene feels so familiar.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
其他人：什么叫似曾相识
Other: What do you mean familiar?
Alice: OK
其他人：好生气啊
Others: So angry!
其他人：都怪那个风
Others: It's all because of the wind.
Shure: 确实
Shure: True.
Shure: 来吧我觉得这波的才艺
Shure: Come on, I think this round's talent...
Jake:很有才艺
Jake: Very talented.
Shure: 123456
Jake: 黄一波
Jake: Huang Yibo
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Shure: 6吧
Shure: It's awesome.
Shure: 再来俩 8个发发发
Shure: Let's get two more, 8 is great.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：凳子把凳子再搬回去呗
Others: Move the chairs back, please.
其他人：都是谁对应的
Others: Who does what?
其他人：凳子好
Others: The chairs are good.
其他人：再拿回去
Others: Move them back.
Alice: Lucia
其他人：真漂亮
Others: So pretty.
Alice: 真漂亮
Alice: So pretty.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Shure: 大家搬搬下凳子
Shure: Everyone, move your chairs.
Shure: 然后回到原位
Shure: And return to your spots.
Shure: 然后我们继续进行这个拍卖环节
Shure: Then we'll continue with the auction segment.
Tasha: 还有谁
Tasha: Who else?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure: 谢斌竹呢
Shure: Where's Xie Binzhu?
Shure: 谢斌竹点
Shure: Xie Binzhu, come on.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure: 谢斌竹
Shure: Xie Binzhu.
其他人：点什么呀
Others: What are you picking?
Shure: 谢斌竹
Shure: Xie Binzhu.
Shure: 你要不先点一下饭吧
Shure: Why don't you start by picking a meal?
Shure: 点了吗刚才
Shure: Did you order just now?
其他人：没有啊
Others: No, not yet.
Shure: 你现在点一下
Shure: Order now.
其他人：我让我姐点
Others: I'll have my sister order.
Shure: 然后点一个
Shure: Then order one.
Shure: 点一个大的那个特别大的披萨
Shure: Order a big one, a really big pizza.
Shure: 然后还有那个点点串
Shure: And also some skewers.
Shure: 随便点烧烤
Shure: Just get some random barbecue.
Lucia: 棒棒感谢哈哈
Lucia: Awesome, thanks haha.
Shure: 怎么
Shure: What?
Shure: 盖上盖上盖
Shure: Cover it, cover it up.
Shure: 干嘛你这样子我现在躺下就可以睡觉了
Shure: What are you doing? If you keep this up, I'll fall asleep right now.
Tasha: 为什么我们才两个
Tasha: Why do we only have two?
Tasha: 一个一个币
Tasha: One coin each.
Tasha: 两个就是
Tasha: Two means...
Shure: 是的啊
Shure: Yeah.
其他人：修硕
Others: Shure.
其他人：24的吗
Others: The 24 one?
Shure: 就是那最大最大的那个
Shure: Yeah, the biggest one.
其他人：点两个
Others: Get two.
Shure: 点
Shure: Order.
Shure: 24的话 24的话咱们是几个人十
Shure: So, if it's 24, how many of us are there, ten?
Shure: 先点一个
Shure: Let's get one first.
Shure: 然后再点点别的吧
Shure: Then order something else.
Lucia: 好久哦表情都不自然了
Lucia: It's been so long, my expression looks unnatural.
其他人：看看你的表情还不自然
Others: Look at your expression, it's still unnatural.
Lucia: 你看后面又过坡了哈哈
Lucia: Look, another bump in the back haha.
其他人：没有
Others: No.
Shure: 怎么不用呢
Shure: Why don't you use it?
Shure: 点了点了
Shure: Ordered, ordered.
Tasha: 呵呵呵呵
Tasha: Hehehehe.
Lucia: 哎还可以好呀
Lucia: Oh, it's still okay, good.
其他人：你刚刚给我捧什么场
Others: What were you trying to support me for earlier?
其他人：你想要的话我在给你剪一张就好了
Others: If you want, I can cut another one for you.
Lucia: 只要有福星出现的地方
Lucia: Wherever there's a lucky star...
Lucia: 他就会变成摄影师
Lucia: He'll turn into a photographer.
Alice: 真好啊
Alice: That's great.
Shure: 你增加点囤货吗
Shure: Do you want to stock up a bit?
Lucia: sorry sorry sorry my fault
Lucia: Sorry, sorry, sorry, my fault.
Lucia: 要不要把它转一下打到脸上
Lucia: Should we turn it to hit the face?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
其他人：可以
Others: Sure.
Lucia: 我们站这边的话可以调
Lucia: If we stand here, we can adjust it.
Lucia: 其实可以调一下
Lucia: Actually, we can adjust it a bit.
Lucia: 让它给脸上补点光之类的
Lucia: Let it add some light to the face or something.
Alice: 那我们站这里
Alice: Then we stand here.
Alice: 差不多
Alice: Almost.
Lucia: 对对可以
Lucia: Yes, yes, that's fine.
Lucia: 抱住
Lucia: Hold on.
Shure: 我有那么落魄吗
Shure: Do I look that down and out?
Shure: 有的
Shure: Yes, you do.
Lucia: 我这个镜框稍有点大
Lucia: This frame is a bit big.
Lucia: 所以汤老师
Lucia: So, Mr. Tang...
Lucia: 哎可以好看
Lucia: Hey, it looks good.
Alice: 谢谢
Alice: Thank you.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah...
其他人：咱俩合格影呗
Others: Let's take a photo together.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Alright, alright, alright.
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Alice: 我我我不太会拍哦
Alice: I'm not really good at taking photos.
Alice: 你就说什么
Alice: What should I say?
Lucia: 他这个相机很
Lucia: This camera is very...
Lucia: 这这这还是你之前的相机吗
Lucia: Is this still your old camera?
Lucia: 你有升级设备吗
Lucia: Did you upgrade your equipment?
其他人：没什么变化
Others: Not much has changed.
Alice: 这可以打鸟吗
Alice: Can this be used for bird watching?
其他人：呃那再换镜头
Others: Uh, we need to change the lens.
其他人：在了
Others: Got it.
Lucia: 哇你怎么带这么齐装备
Lucia: Wow, why did you bring so much gear?
Alice: 我是点这个就可以
Alice: Just press this, right?
Shure: 我们我们
Shure: We, we...
Shure: order
Shure: Order.
其他人：没关系
Others: It's okay.
其他人：拍不出去也没关系的
Others: It's fine if it doesn't turn out well.
Alice: 这是拍上了吗
Alice: Did it take the picture?
Alice: 是不是有点太近了
Alice: Isn't it a bit too close?
其他人：是的没事
Others: Yes, but it's okay.
其他人：待会再说
Others: We'll deal with it later.
Alice: 好谢谢
Alice: Alright, thanks.
Shure: 来吧现在我们下一位拍卖者
Shure: Alright, now our next auctioneer.
Shure: 啊来吧
Shure: Ah, let's go.
其他人： 本次拍卖的东西主要是有两个
Others: There are mainly two items in this auction.
其他人：这个呢是一盒可孚 的牙线棒
Others: This one is a box of Cofco dental floss sticks.
其他人： 为什么要选择这个呢 主要是因为有一句老话叫什么叫
Others: Why choose this? Mainly because there's an old saying, what is it...
Alice: 叫啥呀
Alice: What's it?
其他人：叫啥叫什么
Others: What's it called?
其他人：叫一句老话
Others: An old saying...
其他人：等一下哈哈哈哈
Others: Wait a minute hahaha
其他人：不会是沃斯蒂说的
Others: Could it be what Worthy said?
其他人： 啊麦斯尔夫说的
Others: Ah, it's what Maiself said
Alice:哈哈哈呃
Alice: Hahaha uh
其他人： 说一句是牙齿不是病疼起来真要命这句话
Others: Say the phrase "Teeth aren't a disease, but when they hurt, it's really bad"
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
其他人：你确定这话是麦瑟尔夫说的吗
Others: Are you sure Maiself said that?
其他人： 啊对麦斯尔夫说的
Others: Ah yes, Maiself said it
其他人：所以呢对这个
Others: So, about this
其他人：对牙齿健康口腔健康 对我们来额外的重要
Others: Dental health, oral health, it's extremely important to us
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：所以这就是作为我们的第一件拍卖品
Others: So this is our first auction item
Shure: 所
Shure: So
其他人： 我们从 一个币开始拍
Others: We'll start the bidding at one coin
其他人：一个OK
Others: One, okay
其他人： 一个
Others: One
其他人： OK
Others: Okay
其他人：哈哈哈啊
Others: Hahaha ah
其他人： 一个币一个币还有吗
Others: One coin, one coin, any more?
Jake: 这就是传媒人么
Jake: Is this how media people do it?
其他人：什么招手5个币是吗
Others: Waving means 5 coins, right?
Alice:哈哈哈招手5个币
Alice: Hahaha waving means 5 coins
其他人：一个币一个币一次
Others: One coin, one coin, once
Tasha: 不是我点了多少次餐了
Tasha: Didn't I order multiple times?
Shure: 算了算了
Shure: Forget it, forget it
其他人：一个币两次
Others: One coin, twice
Shure: 一个币两次
Shure: One coin, twice
其他人：三个币是吧
Others: Three coins, right?
Shure: 主
Shure: Main
Tasha: 你你付过了
Tasha: You, you already paid
Alice: 我都没有我跟你讲
Alice: I didn't, I'm telling you
Tasha: 你付了呀
Tasha: You paid!
其他人： OK一个币三次恭喜你
Others: OK, one coin, three times, congratulations
其他人： 太好了
Others: Great
其他人：内不消化
Others: Internal digestion
其他人：内部消化了
其他人：啊对
Others: Ah, yes
Shure: 要
Shure: Need
其他人：照片给我
Others: Give me the photo
其他人：哈哈哈就当就当是他拍的
Others: Hahaha just consider it as he won it
其他人：因为他那个小狗没跟我收钱
Others: Because his little dog didn't charge me.
Shure: 亲兄弟明算账是吧
Shure: Clear accounts between brothers, right?
Alice: 在身无分币的年纪遇见了最想要的啥
Alice: At the age when I had no money, I met the thing I wanted most.
Alice: 牙线棒是吗哈哈哈
Alice: Dental floss picks, right? Hahaha.
其他人： OKOK接下来 是我们第二个拍品是一本书叫 月亮河6
Others: OK, OK, next, our second auction item is a book called "Moon River 6."
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahahaha.
其他人： 不会是盗版书吧
Others: It can't be a pirated book, right?
Shure: 盗版书哈哈哈
Shure: A pirated book, hahaha.
其他人：不能吧我看一下
Others: No way, let me take a look.
Alice: 你从哪偷的你跟我说说
Alice: Where did you steal it from? Tell me.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahahaha.
其他人：OKOK就是 有这么一本书啊 俗话说的好
Others: OK, OK, so we have this book, as the saying goes.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What?
Shure: 我好一脸懵
Shure: I'm so confused.
其他人： 这个书籍是人类进步的阶梯 这个应该不是我说的
Others: This book is a ladder to human progress. I didn't say that.
其他人： 那么我们是的是的那
Others: So, we are... yes, that...
Shure: 这是高尔基说的
Shure: That's what Gorky said.
其他人： 那我们这个第二件拍卖品起步价一个币
Others: So, our second auction item starts at one coin.
其他人：一个币哈哈哈
Others: One coin, hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahahaha.
其他人：一个币一次
Others: One coin, once.
Shure: 这绝版的这书都
Shure: This is a rare book.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahahaha.
其他人：这可是月亮河六便士 哈哈哈
Others: This is the "Moon River Sixpence," hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahahaha.
Shure: 我看看这到底是谁
Shure: Let me see who this is by.
其他人： 可能就是译文有问题应该是原版
Others: Maybe the translation is the problem, it should be the original.
Shure: 吧
Shure: Right.
其他人： 应该是一个看起来很像盗版正版书
Others: It looks like a very pirated original book.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahahaha.
其他人：满地都是月亮他却抬头看到6便士
Others: The ground is full of moons, but he looks up and sees sixpence.
Shure: 是那个
Shure: It's that one.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahahaha.
其他人：我最讨厌的作者之一
Others: One of my least favorite authors.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahaha.
其他人： 一个币两次
Others: One coin, twice.
Shure: 两个币
Shure: Two coins.
其他人：OK两个币一次
Others: OK, two coins per turn.
其他人： 这么胜券再握书都拿走了
Others: So confident, taking all the books away.
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
其他人：两个币两次哦
Others: Two coins for two turns.
Shure: 谢斌竹出3个币
Shure: Xie Binzhu bids 3 coins.
其他人：什么什么
Others: What, what?
Shure: 谢云珠出3
Shure: Xie Yunzhu bids 3.
Tasha: 他出3个币
Tasha: He bids 3 coins.
其他人： OK三个币 一次
Others: OK, three coins, once.
其他人：这个错版书错版书三个币两次
Others: This misprint book, misprint book, three coins, twice.
其他人：OK三个币三次成交
Others: OK, three coins, three times, sold.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
其他人：谢云竹拿钱
Others: Xie Yunzhu, pay up.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 银行突然多了3块钱的
Shure: The bank suddenly has 3 more coins.
Lucia: 哈哈突然负债3个
Lucia: Haha, suddenly 3 coins in debt.
其他人：恭喜你
Others: Congratulations.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha.
其他人：我想说为什么说它错版
Others: I want to know why it's a misprint.
Shure: 因为月亮和六便士
Shure: Because of "The Moon and Sixpence."
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 哦谢斌竹觉得还挺对的哈哈哈
Shure: Oh, Xie Binzhu thinks it's quite right, hahaha.
其他人： 月亮与六便士那么翻译问题吗我操
Others: "The Moon and Sixpence", is it a translation issue, damn.
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, yes.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
其他人：支持正版支持正版
Others: Support original, support original.
其他人：这还蛮好看的
Others: This is quite good.
Shure: 来吧来吧 3个币
Shure: Come on, come on, 3 coins.
其他人：从公家出啊
Others: From public funds.
其他人：是这样的
Others: That's right.
其他人：他给的是吧
Others: He gave it, right?
Shure: 啊他给了是吧
Shure: Ah, he gave it, right?
Shure: 啊啊我以为他
Shure: Ah, ah, I thought he...
Alice: 别说出来
Alice: Don't say it.
Alice: 你这不偷偷拿6个
Alice: Aren't you secretly taking 6?
Alice: 你给我
Alice: You give me...
Shure: 他从他从世界银行走的
Shure: He took it from the World Bank.
Shure: 我以为
Shure: I thought...
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 怒赚6个
Lucia: Earned 6 angrily.
Shure: 我们下一位没了吧是吧
Shure: We don't have the next one, right?
Shure: 还有还有
Shure: Oh wait, we do.
Shure: 小杜
Shure: Xiao Du.
其他人： 我从学校带来一钥匙链 行胜一言钥匙链
Others: I brought a keychain from school, a "Words to Action" keychain.
其他人：好我就要拍了
Others: Okay, I'm gonna take a photo.
其他人：这个相当 我这个跟了我半年里面积攒了我所有写代码的怨恨
Others: This keychain, it's been with me for half a year, storing all my coding frustrations.
其他人： 那个我大脑骂人的 语气我下班回家的开心还有那 在学校里面
Others: My brain's cursing, my joy of coming home after work, and in school...
其他人：这上面有有怨灵哈哈哈
Others: This has some grudges, haha.
其他人：那个学校
Others: That school...
其他人： 怨灵
Others: Grudges.
Shure: 清华一个两个三个4个他们四
Shure: Tsinghua, one, two, three, four, they have four.
其他人：已经附魔了已经附魔了
Others: It's already enchanted, already enchanted.
其他人：开过光的开过光的
Others: It's blessed, it's blessed.
其他人：你要再再再
Others: You need more, more, more...
其他人：一个是清华校徽
Others: One is Tsinghua's emblem.
其他人：这边有清华大学
Others: This side has Tsinghua University.
其他人：一个是二校门
Others: One is the second gate.
其他人：一个是那个日晷上的那个
Others: One is the sundial.
其他人：一共三一共三合一我觉得大家可以拍一下
Others: Altogether three, I think everyone can take a photo.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go.
Shure: 那么我们现在开始一个币的起拍
Shure: Now we start the bidding at one coin.
Shure: 一个一个
Shure: One, one...
其他人：一个
Others: One.
Shure: l同学出一个一个币一次
Shure: L student bids one coin once.
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Tasha: 我让他5分钟后到店
Tasha: I'll have him at the store in 5 minutes.
其他人：好大概多少分钟到家
Others: Okay, how many minutes to get home?
Tasha: 大概多长时间做好
Tasha: How long will it take?
Shure: 艾鲁艾鲁同学出了两个
Shure: Elu, Elu bids two coins.
Tasha: 喂
Tasha: Hello?
Shure: 两个币一次
Shure: Two coins once.
Shure: 2个币两次
Shure: Two coins twice.
其他人：这么大的东西才两个币
Others: Such a big thing for only two coins.
其他人：我的天
Others: My god.
其他人：这店里挺贵的呢
Others: It's quite expensive in the store.
其他人：三个
Others: Three
Shure: 3个3个币一次
Shure: Three coins at a time
Shure: 主办有没有想想想想要的3个币的啊
Shure: Does the host want three coins or not?
Alice: 可以可以
Alice: Sure, sure.
Alice: 给我掏钱吗
Alice: Are you paying for me?
Lucia: 超过了我的存款
Lucia: That's more than my savings.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 3个币一次
Shure: Three coins at a time
Shure: 3个币两次
Shure: Three coins twice
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 走世界银行
Lucia: Go to the World Bank
其他人：贷款
Others: Loan
Alice: 我可以带4个币吗
Alice: Can I have four coins?
Shure: 我出4个
Shure: I'll give you four.
Shure: 4个币一次4个币两次了
Shure: Four coins at a time, four coins twice
其他人：5个老公给我买
Others: Five, my husband will buy it for me
Alice: 老公给我买
Alice: My husband will buy it for me
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh dear
Lucia: 5个5个5个5个5个5个5个5个5个5个5个5个
Lucia: Five, five, five, five, five, five, five, five, five, five, five, five
Alice: 我我出的四个呀
Alice: I offered four, right?
Shure: 5个币一次
Shure: Five coins at a time
Alice: 4是我出的呀
Alice: I offered four!
Alice: 你压我干啥
Alice: Why are you outbidding me?
Shure: 5个币两次
Shure: Five coins twice
Shure: 5个币3次
Shure: Five coins three times
Alice: 我没有
Alice: I don't have it.
Tasha: 算了吧小程序点吧
Tasha: Forget it, just use the app.
Alice: 我不都贷款吗
Alice: Didn't I already take a loan?
Shure: 成交
Shure: Deal.
其他人：稍等我先给你点点钱
Others: Wait, let me give you some money first.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 你就把这个码报给他
Tasha: Just give him this code.
其他人：我想我要不要轰财物价来着
Others: I wonder if I should blast the prices.
Tasha: 然后你说大概多长时间做好
Tasha: Then ask how long it'll take.
其他人：没事儿你从我这10个币买走
Others: No worries, you can buy it from me for ten coins.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 他人家就是那学校的哈哈哈
Shure: It's just from that school, haha
其他人：这才叫轰财物价
Others: Now that's price blasting.
其他人：哈哈哈二道贩子
Others: Hahaha, middleman
其他人：我为什么会需要这种道具啊
Others: Why would I need this kind of item?
Shure: 还有还有奥
Shure: There's more, oh
Shure: 什么any auction animal
Shure: What any auction animal?
Tasha: 不卖了
Tasha: Not selling anymore
其他人：不卖了
Jake: 不卖了不卖了
Jake: Not selling, not selling
Tasha: 不知道不知道
Tasha: No idea, no idea
Tasha: 随便吧姐啊啊
Tasha: Whatever, sis, ah
Jake: 卖卖卖卖卖一部卖一部
Jake: Sell, sell, sell, sell one part, sell one part
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Shure: 啊大家可以看到啊
Shure: Ah, everyone can see, ah
Shure: 我们的大厨上来吧
Shure: Our chef, come up
Shure: 来来我们的我们的
Shure: Come, come, our, our
Shure: 甜点甜点
Shure: Dessert, dessert
Shure: king desert king还是desert king来着
Shure: King dessert, king or dessert king?
其他人： 我还要找骑手干嘛 呀
Others: Do I still need to find the rider?
Shure: desert还是desert desert吧
Shure: Dessert or desert, desert then
其他人：这个算拍卖里面吗
Others: Does this count in the auction?
其他人：啊这是拍
Others: Ah, this is auction
其他人： 是呀
Others: Yeah
其他人：刚才都
Others: Just now, all
其他人：花钱花的太早了
Others: Spent money too early
其他人：天呐要不要考虑这个
Others: Oh my, should we consider this?
其他人：首先呢我们先征一下赔款
Others: First, let's collect some compensation
其他人：就刚刚吃了
Others: Just now we ate
其他人：先把币拿上来
Others: Let's get the coins first
其他人：你内个不是你内叫
Others: You, that, didn't you call
其他人：你内叫什么销售
Others: What did you call that sales?
其他人：我那个叫试吃
Others: I called it a tasting
其他人：对对对我我是试吃
Others: Yes, yes, I was tasting
其他人：因为我是我是拍的
Others: Because I was auctioning
其他人：我是帮我姐拍的
Others: I was bidding for my sister
其他人：所以我刚先试吃一下
Others: So I tasted it first
其他人：确保她的是正事
Others: To make sure it's legit
其他人：我已经试吃过
Others: I've already tasted it
其他人：她确认是正事
Others: She confirmed it's legit
其他人：然后这个水果就可以不算
Others: And then, this fruit won't count
其他人：水果就不算了
Others: Fruit won't count
其他人：这个这个吃了
Others: This, this eaten
其他人：刚刚我们可以先按整整个一个币啊
Others: Just now we can count one coin for the whole thing
其他人：然后交上来
Others: And then submit it
其他人：先交上来
Others: Hand it over first.
其他人：刚刚谁吃了
Others: Who just ate it?
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
Alice: 调监控
Alice: Check the surveillance.
其他人：我们可以先把下面的都我有15台监控
Others: We can first look at all the 15 cameras we have.
其他人：大家我先把剩下卖完
Others: Everyone, let's sell the rest first.
其他人：我们最后再来找这个人是是谁
Others: We'll find out who it is later.
其他人：首先我们可以先卖这个抹茶蛋挞
Others: First, we can sell this matcha tart.
其他人：这个我吃了
Others: I ate this one.
其他人：非常好吃
Others: It's really delicious.
其他人：这个东西它的价值在于
Others: The value of this thing lies in
其他人：抹茶粉非常的贵
Others: The matcha powder is very expensive.
其他人：以至于
Others: So much so that
其他人：撒抹茶粉和撒结的方法是不一样的
Others: The method of sprinkling matcha powder is different.
其他人：呃它的味道的特点呢
Others: Uh, the taste characteristic is
其他人：在于很像日本的什么
Others: It's very similar to Japanese...
其他人：什么抹茶
Others: Some kind of matcha.
其他人：反正就是非常的好吃
Others: Anyway, it's very delicious.
其他人：那我们起拍价就按一共只有两个
Others: So we start the bidding price, since we only have two.
其他人：所以
Others: So
其他人：我们更希望它能成双成对的卖出去
Others: We hope to sell them as a pair.
其他人：所以我们起拍价就按一个蛋挞一个币
Others: So we start the bidding price at one tart for one coin.
其他人：一个蛋挞一个
Others: One tart for
其他人：抹茶比较贵最后一个蛋挞一个币
Others: Matcha is more expensive, so one tart for one coin.
Shure: 币一个蛋挞一个币
Shure: One coin for one tart.
Shure: 我真好饿呀
Shure: I'm so hungry.
Shure: 你先给我来一个
Shure: Give me one first.
其他人：拍拍拍
Others: Bid, bid, bid.
Shure: 我出我出一个币
Shure: I'll bid, I'll bid one coin.
其他人：好一个亿有没有啊
Others: Okay, one coin, anyone else?
其他人：因为我们只有两个抹茶
Others: Because we only have two matcha.
其他人：剩下这些都比较多剩下这些都比较多
Others: The rest are more common, the rest are more common.
Shure: OK成交成交
Shure: OK, deal, deal.
Shure: 来吧给你一个币
Shure: Here, take one coin.
Shure: 我可以再
Shure: Can I
Shure: 拿一个吗
Shure: Take another one?
其他人：再拿一个就是另外价钱
Others: Another one will cost extra.
其他人：因为他现在已经只剩一个
Others: Because now there's only one left.
其他人：他就他等于要升级
Others: It means it has to be upgraded.
其他人：你先你先拿一个
Others: You go first, you take one first.
Shure: OK我先拿一个
Shure: OK, I'll take one first.
其他人：你可以考虑拿第二个
Others: You can consider taking the second one.
Shure: 这个是吗
Shure: Is this the one?
其他人：可以可以
Others: Yes, yes.
其他人：这是蛋挞吗
Others: Is this a tart?
其他人：这带盘的一会再拍哦
Others: We'll take a photo with the plate later.
Shure: 不吃啊
Shure: Not eating it?
其他人：好那我们拍第二个
Others: Okay, then we'll take a photo with the second one.
其他人：因为他现在只剩一个
Others: Because there's only one left now.
其他人：所以我们可以附赠一个
Others: So we can add one more for free.
其他人：你举着抹茶蛋挞拍照的机会可以吧
Others: You can take a photo holding the matcha tart, right?
其他人：所以我们这个呢
Others: So this one...
其他人：所以我这个
Others: So this...
其他人：可以附赠一个举着抹茶蛋挞拍照
Others: You can add one more for a photo holding the matcha tart.
其他人：所以呢按你的价值两
Others: So, according to its value, two...
其他人：但我们还有一个币起拍
Others: But we still start with one coin.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
其他人：一个币还有没有别的了一个币起拍
Others: One coin, is there nothing else? Start with one coin.
其他人：我来找骑手
Others: I'll find the rider.
其他人：那剩下的是骑手的责任
Others: Then the rest is the rider's responsibility.
其他人：不是你的责任哪个
Others: Not your responsibility, which one?
其他人：好好还有吗
Others: Okay, is there any more?
其他人：没有只有一个币
Others: No, only one coin.
其他人：快那你那你嗖的一下
Others: Quick, you, quickly.
其他人：快没声了
Others: Quick, there's no sound.
其他人：嗖嗖的吗
Others: Quick, quick?
其他人：来上来你可以跟他拍个照片啊
Others: Come on up, you can take a photo with him.
其他人：我要和他合照
Others: I want to take a photo with him.
其他人：对你可以你可以啊
Others: Yes, you can, you can.
其他人：你卖的是合照钱不是商品哦
Others: You're selling the photo opportunity, not the product.
其他人：商品和合照钱
Others: The product and the photo opportunity.
Shure: 你这有兜吗
Shure: Do you have a pocket?
其他人：你可以跟他合照
Others: You can take a photo with him.
其他人：和这架子合照
Others: With this frame.
其他人：或者你想单独举着它也可以
Others: Or you can hold it alone if you want.
Lucia: 哎我把我手机扔哪了
Lucia: Hey, where did I throw my phone?
其他人：哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahahahahahahaha.
其他人：你为什么卖的是人家的合照
Others: Why are you selling someone else's photo opportunity?
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
其他人：我们是友好合作
Others: We are working together friendly.
其他人：一会给你冠名
Others: We'll name it after you later.
其他人：钱我可以白送你的啊
Others: I can give you the money for free.
其他人：好好好哈哈
Others: Alright, alright, haha.
Tasha: 哈有种帅哥明星甜品合照的感觉
Tasha: Ha, it feels like a handsome star dessert photo shoot.
其他人：我们今天要吃哪个
Others: Which one are we eating today?
其他人：这个是巧克力粉
Others: This is chocolate powder.
其他人：比较适合巧克力的重度爱好
Others: It's more suitable for chocolate enthusiasts.
其他人：虽然虽然我我就
Others: Although, although, I...
其他人：和主厨握手的机会
Others: The chance to shake hands with the chef.
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
其他人：我就很喜欢吃这个所以它就剩了一个
Others: I really like eating this, so there's only one left.
其他人：这个里面它的优势在于它有这个
Others: Its advantage lies in its...
Lucia: 怎么是所以啊哈哈
Lucia: Why "so"? Haha.
其他人：这个巧克力豆比草莓就味道就不一样
Others: This chocolate chip tastes different from strawberry.
其他人：他自己黑下几个
Others: He blackened a few himself.
其他人：非常契合这个巧克力粉的设计理念
Others: It perfectly fits the design concept of chocolate powder.
其他人：因为考虑到他也是孤品呢
Others: Considering it's a unique item.
其他人：就可以和主厨握一下手
Others: You can shake hands with the chef.
其他人：这个握手的价钱呢
Others: The price for the handshake...
其他人：另算呃但是呢
Others: It's separate, but...
其他人：只要你握手我们就碰到了合照的机会
Others: As long as you shake hands, we have a chance for a photo.
其他人：对吧
Others: Right?
其他人：所以所以起拍价是一个币然后握手呢
Others: So, the starting price is one coin, and the handshake...
其他人：握一个币
Others: One coin for the handshake.
其他人：哎一会坐下去吃哈哈哈
Others: Hey, let's sit down and eat later, haha.
Shure: 一会坐进去了
Shure: We'll sit down later.
其他人：我们当然我也可以单独开这个
Others: Of course, we can open this separately.
其他人：我们也可以先不握手
Others: We can choose not to shake hands first.
Shure: 怎么看展看多了看什么都像了是吗
Shure: After seeing so many exhibitions, everything looks the same, right?
其他人：因为后面握手机会还要很高
Others: Because there will be more handshake opportunities later.
其他人：然后我们起开价是一个币
Others: Then our starting price is one coin.
其他人：别拍了不要拍了
Others: Stop filming, don't film anymore.
Shure: 一个币
Shure: One coin.
其他人：一个币
其他人：一个币真的没有吗
Others: Really, no coin?
Shure: 牛币一次
Shure: One coin once.
其他人：坏了要流派了这个时候需要有一个内部人员出点钱
Others: Oh no, we need someone internally to put up some money.
Tasha: 我给了他一个啊
Tasha: I gave him one.
Shure: 我出我出我出一个币
Shure: I'll bid, I'll bid, I'll bid one coin.
其他人：ok
Others: Okay.
其他人：还要点什么烤串
Others: Do you want to order some more skewers?
Tasha: 还要点什么烤串
Tasha: Do you want to order some more skewers?
其他人：那如果没有的话那就
Others: If not, then...
其他人：那就又又拍给你了
Others: Then I'll just give it to you again.
其他人：你给我一个币就可以了
Others: Just give me one coin and that's fine.
其他人：那你那你要和主厨握手啊
Others: Then you need to shake hands with the chef.
Shure: 我一会再过吧
Shure: I'll come over later.
其他人：一会再过那就是两个币哈哈
Others: If you come over later, then it'll cost you two coins, haha.
其他人：握手可以拍照
Others: You can take a photo while shaking hands.
其他人：你还可以选择你握手
Others: You can also choose to shake hands.
Shure: 算了算了算了哈哈哈
Shure: Never mind, never mind, haha.
其他人：那那你可以把这个拿出来
Others: Then you can take this out.
Shure: 谢谢谢谢
Shure: Thank you, thank you.
其他人：多么有戏剧性的一种片
Others: What a dramatic scene.
其他人：呃剩下的我们可以先拍这个麻薯
Others: Uh, for the rest, we can first shoot this mochi.
其他人：这个麻薯我们是做盒卖的哦
Others: We're selling this mochi in boxes.
其他人：这个我们就一个
Others: We only have one.
其他人：一盒一个币
Others: One box for one coin.
其他人：因为这个麻薯属于限量制作
Others: Because this mochi is made in limited quantities.
其他人：但是蛋挞它属于特别
Others: But the egg tarts are special.
其他人：制作而且蛋挞都是孤品
Others: Each egg tart is unique.
其他人：麻薯它现在还不是孤品
Others: The mochi isn't unique yet.
其他人：我们是市场调节的
Others: We're adjusting according to market demand.
其他人：好吧这个我们第一个人买的是微信
Others: Okay, the first person to buy will use WeChat.
其他人：第一个人买可以选这个和这个就后面
Others: The first person to buy can choose between this and that, later...
Shure: 好吃吧
Shure: Is it tasty?
Shure: 虽然看着不好
Shure: Even though it doesn't look good.
其他人：比如说如果第一个人选了
Others: For example, if the first person chooses...
其他人：他后面就只有巧克力了
Others: Then there will only be chocolate left.
Shure: 看着没那么好看
Shure: It doesn't look that good.
Shure: 但是很好吃
Shure: But it's really tasty.
其他人：拿我们还是一个币起拍
Others: Then we'll start the bidding at one coin.
Tasha: 有两个口味
Tasha: There are two flavors.
其他人：对有两个口味
Others: Yes, there are two flavors.
其他人：第一个买的人是你选的
Others: The first buyer is you, choose.
其他人：来一个币
Others: One coin.
其他人：看好了一个币有没有加价的
Others: Look closely, one coin, any higher bids?
其他人：都可以选口味
Others: You can choose the flavor.
其他人：这个口味
Others: This flavor
其他人：是是是是是巧克力和
Others: Yes, yes, yes, it's chocolate and
其他人：巧克力和啥呀
Others: Chocolate and what?
Tasha: 豆乳
Tasha: Soy milk
其他人：啊
Others: Ah
Tasha: 豆乳好好
Tasha: Soy milk, okay
Tasha: 和豆粉吧
Tasha: And soybean powder
其他人：好好OK OK
Others: Okay, okay, OK, OK
其他人：豆乳豆乳
Others: Soy milk, soy milk
Alice: 我快没story了
Alice: I'm running out of stories
其他人：两个
Others: Two
其他人：两个好
Others: Two is good
其他人：两个币可以选口味
Others: Two coins can pick a flavor
其他人：这位先生
Others: Sir
其他人：用两个币争取到选口味的机会
Others: Use two coins to get a chance to pick a flavor
其他人：还有没有了
Others: Is there any left?
其他人：好
Others: Okay
其他人：so那你可以来选一个口味
Others: So, now you can pick a flavor
Lucia: 那是应该有一包
Lucia: That should be one pack
其他人：就是一个两个巧克力
Others: Just one, two chocolates
其他人：你要巧克力
Others: You want chocolate?
其他人：好呀那我们现在拍卖还可以选口味
Others: Okay, so now we can auction and still pick a flavor
其他人：还可以选口味非常的宝贵
Others: Still can pick a flavor, very valuable
其他人：因为你后面不拍的话就买不到
Others: Because if you don't bid later, you can't buy it
其他人：就没有办法选口味
Others: There's no way to pick a flavor
其他人：那我们依旧是一个币起拍
Others: So we'll start with one coin
其他人：但是我们历史参考价都是两个币
Others: But our historical reference price is two coins
其他人：历史参考价是两个币
Others: Historical reference price is two coins
其他人：好有没有出价的
Others: Okay, any bids?
其他人：来一个币
Others: One coin
其他人：两个
Others: Two
其他人：好两个币还有没有了
Others: Okay, two coins, any more bids?
Shure: 就是不让老板吃上饭是吧
Shure: So we won't let the boss eat, right?
其他人：哈哈哈还有没有
Others: Hahaha, any more bids?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
其他人：好那就两个币
Others: Okay, so two coins
其他人：你选一个你选一个看你要哪个
Others: You pick one, you pick one, see which one you want
其他人：很明显上面那个在市场上不受欢迎
Others: It's obvious the one on top is not popular in the market
其他人：完了上面这个在市场上不受欢
Others: Yeah, the one on top is not popular in the market
其他人：迎那那
Others: Welcome, welcome.
其他人：剩下感觉不好卖
Others: The rest don't seem to sell well.
Katrina: 剩下你自己吃吧
Katrina: The rest, you eat them yourself.
其他人：鉴于你的这个麻薯的麻薯
Others: Considering your mochi, the mochi.
其他人：剩余的麻薯在市场上活动
Others: The remaining mochi in the market.
其他人：我们可以可以等待时间检验一下
Others: We can wait and let time test it out.
其他人：我们现在先拍这个纸杯蛋糕
Others: For now, let's shoot this cupcake.
其他人：这是一个新品
Others: This is a new product.
其他人：这个纸杯蛋糕
Others: This cupcake.
其他人：它的优势在于它附赠一个纸杯
Others: Its advantage is that it comes with a paper cup.
其他人：这是一个非常环保的纸杯
Others: This is a very eco-friendly paper cup.
其他人：而且它这上面的草莓呢
Others: And it has quite a few strawberries on it.
其他人：个数比较多
Others: Quite a lot.
其他人：至少都是有两半草莓
Others: At least two halves of strawberries.
其他人：我们刚刚卖过的这个抹茶蛋挞
Others: The matcha tart we just sold.
其他人： 上面只有半片草莓
Others: Only had half a strawberry on it.
其他人：呃同样
Others: Uh, similarly.
其他人：这个纸杯蛋糕是一个币一个
Others: This cupcake is one coin each.
其他人：但是两个币三个
Others: But two coins for three.
其他人：所以我们就可以任意的价格起牌
Others: So we can start the bidding at any price.
其他人：一个币
Others: One coin.
其他人：买一个还是两个币
Others: Buy one, or two coins.
其他人：买3个你可以请吗好
Others: Buy three, can you please?
其他人：没人出价要留拍了一个币
Others: No one bid, so we'll keep it at one coin.
其他人：来一个币
Others: One coin.
其他人：一个币来一个币
Others: One coin, one coin.
其他人：那你要要一个吗
Others: Do you want one?
其他人：啊好你们是一个一个卖的吗
Others: Ah, are you selling one by one?
其他人：我也可以两个币三个卖
Others: I can also sell three for two coins.
其他人：一个币一个两个币三个
Others: One coin each, two coins for three.
Lucia: 你俩到底谁在以毒乱回你
Lucia: Who on earth is confusing things here?
其他人：你买不买两个币就是三个
Others: Are you buying? Two coins for three.
其他人：对我没有两个币
Others: I don't have two coins.
其他人：你没有两个币
Others: You don't have two coins?
其他人：那你可以向世界银行贷一个
Others: Then you can borrow one from the World Bank.
其他人：哈哈哈不信
Others: Haha, you don't believe it.
其他人：你是应该先去银行贷啊
Others: You should go to the bank first.
其他人：不你可以一个币买一个
Others: Or you can buy one for one coin.
其他人：你也可以两个币买三个
Others: Or buy three for two coins.
其他人：好那你那你要给我两个币
Others: Okay, then give me two coins.
其他人：你只要给我两个币
Other: You just need to give me two coins.
其他人：我就可以把它送给你
Other: Then I can give it to you.
Shure: 好坏了下面还有一个
Shure: Oh no, there's another one below.
Shure: 完了哈哈哈
Shure: We're done, hahaha.
Shure: 两个币买4个
Shure: Two coins for four.
Shure: 我觉得可以
Shure: I think it's doable.
Shure: 那也可以
Shure: That works too.
Shure: 那就那就两个币买4个吧
Shure: So, let's do two coins for four.
Shure: 好我们薄利多销一下
Shure: Alright, let's make a small profit with more sales.
Shure: 那
Shure: Then,
Shure: 那我可以把这个把这个盒子送给你
Shure: Then I can give you this box.
其他人：你要给我两个币
Other: You need to give me two coins.
Katrina: 其他人：
Katrina: Other:
其他人：好的 世界银行拿一个
Other: Okay, the World Bank takes one.
其他人：你是银行大股东
Other: You're a major shareholder of the bank.
其他人：反正已经反正已经带了
Other: Anyway, it's already taken.
其他人：觉得我们可以走一下
Other: I think we can go.
其他人：迅速销售
Other: Quick sale.
其他人：那改这东西没法卖呀
Other: We can't sell this thing.
其他人：这东西卖的不能让他连盆直接端走呀
Other: We can't just let them take the whole pot away.
Shure: 那大家就那个
Shure: So everyone just, uh...
其他人：那那我们可以一会再卖
Other: Maybe we can sell it later.
其他人：我们可以先中场休息一下
Other: We can take a break now.
Lucia: 这个产品是
Lucia: This product is...
其他人：我们甜品的部分在拍卖穿插当中进行
Other: We'll auction off our dessert part in between.
Lucia: 我已经蹲了很长时间了
Lucia: I've been squatting for a long time.
Lucia: 等待吃他
Lucia: Waiting to eat it.
Katrina: 直接room turo吧
Katrina: Let's go directly to Room Turo.
Katrina: 然后要吃饭了
Katrina: And then have a meal.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yep.
其他人：没破呢这个本来是第二个环节
Other: It hasn't broken yet, this was supposed to be the second round.
其他人：确实还没破呢现在已经是最后一个了
Other: It really hasn't broken yet, now it's already the last one.
Tasha: 嗯还有四五十分钟
Tasha: Hmm, still about fifty minutes left.
Tasha: 一个小时
Tasha: One hour.
Lucia: 哎你粘了一个
Lucia: Hey, you stuck one on.
Lucia: 那个小眼睛
Lucia: That little eye.
其他人：对我这个耳钉掉了然后不知道在哪就用这个代替
Other: Yeah, my earring fell off and I didn't know where it went, so I used this instead.
Alice: 下一环是啥呀
Alice: What's the next round?
Katrina: tourtour来吧
Katrina: Tourtour, let's go.
其他人：我操
Other: Damn.
Shure: 参观房间
Shure: Let's tour the room
Alice: 我我我没把那个梗去掉
Alice: I, I, I didn't remove that joke
其他人：我收你20%佣金不过分吧
Others: Charging you a 20% commission isn't too much, right?
Tasha: 好不过分
Tasha: Not too much
Tasha: 哈哈哎
Tasha: Haha, hey
Alice: 吃吧 哎呀
Alice: Go ahead and eat, oh no
Alice: 绿色的没事
Alice: The green one is fine
Jake: 来我们tour一下
Jake: Alright, let's tour around
Jake:tour一下之后我们就导眼镜
Jake: After the tour, we'll get the glasses
Lucia: 让我再去检查一下我的那个有没有掉
Lucia: Let me check if mine fell off again
Lucia: 这两个是谁
Lucia: Whose are these two?
Lucia: 这个可能是宇轩的吧
Lucia: This might be Yuxuan's, right?
Lucia: 我感觉不是
Lucia: I don't think so
Jake:每个屋子收点门票吧
Jake: Let's charge admission for each room
其他人：我说这是谁买的呢
Others: Who bought this anyway?
Lucia: 哦那我不知道
Lucia: Oh, I don't know
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow
Tasha: 有点
Tasha: A bit
Tasha: 真有点哥真有点
Tasha: Really a bit, bro, really a bit
Shure: 那我的那个闺房十十个
Shure: Then my room, ten tickets
Tasha: 这这消炎药
Tasha: This, this is an anti-inflammatory medicine
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Katrina: 从一楼开始吗
Katrina: Starting from the first floor?
Katrina: 还是什么
Katrina: Or what?
Shure: 从二楼吧从二楼吧来吧
Shure: Let's start from the second floor, come on
Katrina: 来吧
Katrina: Come on
Katrina: 好
Katrina: Okay
Katrina: 见见世面
Katrina: See the world
Katrina: 特意把被子给叠了
Katrina: I specially folded the quilt
Lucia: 呵他又掉了
Lucia: Haha, it fell off again
Lucia: 他又掉了
Lucia: It fell off again
Jake:这个门票多少钱
Jake: How much is the admission ticket?
Katrina: 全全塞这里面了
Katrina: It's all stuffed in here
Shure: 这个门票
Shure: This ticket
Katrina: 哈哈哈就是他给我们
Katrina: Haha, he gave it to us
Jake:这是南极
Jake: This is Antarctica
Katrina: 就是可以
Katrina: It's fine
Katrina: 这是动物派对
Katrina: This is an animal party
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes
Shure: 看看去
Shure: Let's take a look
Katrina: 这当然不是我画的
Katrina: Of course, I didn't draw this.
Jake:来看看去看看去
Jake: Let's take a look.
Katrina: 这我的杰利卡特
Katrina: This is my Jerricart.
Katrina: 那个是我自己抓的娃娃
Katrina: I caught that doll myself.
Katrina: 就那天去
Katrina: Just that day we went...
Katrina: 我们去嗯去游戏厅
Katrina: We went, um, to the arcade.
Katrina: 我自己抓的娃娃
Katrina: I caught the doll myself.
Shure: 这地下到底怎么整的
Shure: What's going on with this floor?
Katrina: 嗯这是动物party
Katrina: Uh, this is an animal party.
Tasha: 看不见
Tasha: I can't see it.
Katrina: 哈哈哈全部都是动物
Katrina: Hahaha, it's all animals.
其他人：感觉就是蚊子叮的
Others: Feels like mosquito bites.
其他人：然后你自己挠破了对
Others: And then you scratched it yourself, right?
Katrina: 然后还有那个
Katrina: And then there's that...
Shure: 真不是你咬的
Shure: You really didn't bite this?
Shure: 我们我们
Shure: We, we...
Shure: 我们room tour room tour
Shure: We're doing a room tour, room tour.
Katrina: 还有香薰是吧
Katrina: And there's an aroma diffuser, right?
其他人：我们room tour
Others: We're doing a room tour.
Shure: 没事以后这种后期都会给我毙掉的
Shure: No worries, these kinds of things will be edited out later.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 当当当当
Katrina: Ta-da!
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Katrina: 换个四件套会更漂亮
Katrina: Changing the bedding will make it prettier.
Katrina: 对是的
Katrina: Yes, it will.
Katrina: next room
Katrina: Next room.
Katrina: nextroom可漂亮了
Katrina: The next room is really pretty.
Jake:那大家准备好
Jake: Everyone, get ready.
Katrina: 多巴胺风格
Katrina: It's dopamine style.
Katrina: 来吧
Katrina: Come on.
Shure: 路及狭财通人
Shure: Roads are narrow and winding.
Katrina: 索
Katrina: Sota.
Katrina: 塔
Katrina: Tower.
Katrina: 什么叫索塔
Katrina: What's Sota?
Katrina: 就是目前最好的
Katrina: It's currently the best.
Katrina: 哦索塔是吗
Katrina: Oh, Sota, right?
Tasha: 是吗哇
Tasha: Really? Wow.
Katrina: 你的真的很漂亮
Katrina: Yours is really pretty.
Lucia: 哇哇好可爱
Lucia: Wow, wow, so cute!
Katrina: 绝了好吗
Katrina: It's amazing, right?
Katrina: 这就是我梦想中的房间
Katrina: This is the room of my dreams.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina: 我拍了给我妈看
Katrina: I took a photo to show my mom.
Lucia: 线条小狗
Lucia: A line drawing of a puppy.
其他人：go人只需要雇一个艺人就可以
Others: You only need to hire one artist.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 勾人被批人的房间震撼到了
Lucia: The room really impressed everyone.
Lucia: 好漂亮
Lucia: So pretty.
Jake:那我们下一个还是要来介绍一下
Jake: Okay, now let's introduce the next one.
Lucia: 好像到我这边了是吧
Lucia: I think it's my turn now, right?
Lucia: 能把这个小小马
Lucia: Can you move this little horse...
Lucia: 还是小狗稍微扳一下吗
Lucia: or this little dog a bit?
Lucia: 要不然大家可能不方便过去哎
Lucia: Otherwise, it might be inconvenient for everyone to pass by.
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 希望他希望我墙上粘的这些胶没有掉
Lucia: I hope the glue on my wall hasn't fallen off.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Lucia: 啊没掉
Lucia: Oh, it didn't fall.
Lucia: 大家快看
Lucia: Everyone, look quickly.
Lucia: 否则他一会就掉了
Lucia: Otherwise, it might fall off soon.
其他人：我看过了
Others: I've seen it already.
其他人：哦你看过了
Others: Oh, you have?
其他人：对我都看过好多次了
Others: Yeah, I've seen it many times.
Lucia: 然后这是一个地中海风格的房间
Lucia: And this is a Mediterranean-style room.
Shure: 地中海风格
Shure: Mediterranean style.
Lucia: 卧槽哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Whoa, hahaha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Shure: 我本来没有那么好奇你
Shure: I wasn't that curious about you initially.
Shure: 你这喊完之后我就想看了你知道吗
Shure: But now, after you said that, I really want to see it, you know?
Katrina: 你一天夸张的好看
Katrina: You look stunning today.
Shure: 哦哦可以可以
Shure: Oh, oh, nice, nice.
Alice: 我也要看
Alice: I want to see it too.
Jake:我靠我投资人表示很开心
Jake: Wow, my investor is really happy.
Shure: 看着很开心
Shure: Looks very nice.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 就是它的整体主色调是蓝色和白色
Shure: The main colors are blue and white.
Lucia: 对就是就是
Lucia: Yes, exactly.
Lucia: 模仿了就是地中海地区
Lucia: It's inspired by the Mediterranean region.
Lucia: 就是可能
Lucia: It's like...
Lucia: 主要是希腊那边
Lucia: Mainly from Greece
Lucia: 最常见的建筑风格的颜色
Lucia: The most common architectural style color
Katrina: 好像参观海洋馆啊
Katrina: Feels like visiting an aquarium
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Ah, right
Katrina: 对是有一点
Katrina: Yes, a bit
Lucia: 是有一点
Lucia: It does a bit
Lucia: 然后是用了墙贴渔网
Lucia: And then I used wall stickers and fishing nets
Lucia: 然后用欧根纱模仿了一个海浪的形状
Lucia: Then used organza to mimic the shape of waves
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow
Lucia: 对然后就随时都可以看到小鱼
Lucia: Yes, then you can see little fish anytime
Shure: 非常棒
Shure: Very nice
Jake:空调开了鱼还会飞
Lucia: 哦你说的很有道理
Lucia: Oh, you have a point
Lucia: 要不然现在开开试试
Lucia: How about we try it now?
Lucia: 哈哈不行
Lucia: Haha, no, that won't work
Lucia: 这个因为我用的是那个
Lucia: Because I used that
Lucia: 就是那种粘性比较弱的纸
Lucia: That kind of low-adhesive paper
Lucia: 害怕在墙上留印子嘛
Lucia: Afraid it will leave marks on the wall
Lucia: 所以如果风太大可能就会掉
Lucia: So if the wind is too strong, it might fall
Lucia: 但是我觉得领导这个提议非常不错
Lucia: But I think your suggestion is great
Lucia: 下次对对对
Lucia: Next time, yes, yes
Lucia: 回家我就把它改成强力胶
Lucia: When I get home, I'll change it to strong adhesive
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
其他人：能和你房间合影吗
Others: Can we take a picture with your room?
Lucia: 可以啊
Lucia: Sure
Lucia: 也也可以
Lucia: Also, yes
Lucia: 不过这个房间其实稍微有一点点乱的
Lucia: But this room is actually a bit messy
Lucia: 还是
Lucia: Still
Lucia: 那我在这站一下好了
Lucia: I'll just stand here then
其他人：要坐床上吗
Others: Should we sit on the bed?
Lucia: 呃没事就不坐了吧
Lucia: Uh, it's okay, let's not sit
Lucia: 坐了这床可能更乱
Lucia: Sitting might make the bed messier
其他人：那个栗栗
Others: That Lili
其他人：如果你站着就会挡到你后面的墙画
Others: If you stand, you'll block the wall art behind you
其他人：栗子填的
Others: Filled by Lizi
其他人：收件地址是你是吗
Others: The shipping address is yours, right?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
其他人：然后他给我一块寄了一个
Others: Then he sent me one too
其他人：他给我一个小玩偶巨丑的那种
Others: He sent me a little doll, a really ugly one
其他人：啊然后你你收到之后你你别私吞
Others: Ah, when you receive it, don't keep it for yourself
Shure: 为什么
Shure: Why?
其他人：因为那是我的啊
Others: Because it's mine!
Shure: 不行那是我的
Shure: No way, it's mine.
Shure: 你一说巨丑我就想要了
Shure: When you said it's super ugly, I wanted it.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Alice:居然是住了人的
Alice: There's actually someone living here.
其他人：有没有可能是住两个人
Others: Could it be two people living here?
其他人：我以为这是个工作间就是负责导数据
Others: I thought this was just a workspace for data management.
其他人：没想到这里一半是工作一半是生活嘛
Others: Turns out it's half work and half living space.
其他人：你给我留着
Others: Save it for me.
其他人：那是他特地跟我说给我的
Others: He specifically told me it was for me.
Alice: 好那可以看我的了
Alice: Alright, now you can look at mine.
Alice: 我的在边边角角
Alice: Mine is in the corner.
其他人：我挑的所以你不能挑
Others: I picked it, so you can't choose.
Shure: 那你让他再给我挑一个街哈哈哈
Shure: Then have him pick another one for me, haha.
Alice: 你们来进吧
Alice: Come on in, you guys.
Shure: 哎呦sorry不好意思
Shure: Oh, sorry, my bad.
其他人：我真不舍得
Others: I really don't want to leave.
其他人：现在还不能看现在还处在闲人免进
Others: We can't see it yet, it's still restricted access.
Shure: 等一下等一下
Shure: Wait a minute, wait a minute.
Tasha: 好乱啊
Tasha: It's so messy.
Tasha: 怎么了
Tasha: What's going on?
其他人：哇
Shure: 你快快快
Shure: Hurry, hurry, hurry.
Shure: 等一下
Shure: Wait a second.
Shure: 被子还没有叠
Shure: The bed isn't made yet.
其他人：哈哈哈哈被子还没有叠
Others: Hahaha, the bed isn't made yet.
其他人：对对对他已经没有机会叠被子了
Others: Yeah, yeah, he doesn't even have a chance to make the bed anymore.
其他人：他已经没有时间叠被子
Others: He doesn't have time to make the bed.
其他人：金康现在还不被允许参观
Others: Jin Kang isn't allowed to visit yet.
Shure: 好就是
Shure: Alright, that's it.
其他人：简约是吧
Others: Simple, right?
Shure: 朴朴素素就是真
Shure: Plain and simple, that's true.
Lucia: 好好
Lucia: Alright, alright.
Tasha: 殴下了
Tasha: Oh, it's down.
Shure: 这个被子是叠过的啊大家哈哈哈
Shure: The bed is made, everyone, hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这被子叠的好呀叠的好啊
Lucia: Hahaha, this bed is well made, very well made.
Shure: 叠的好吧
Shure: Nicely stacked, huh?
Lucia: 这个这个他他在里面吗
Lucia: Is he, is he inside here?
Katrina: 我我比他多一点颜色呵呵呵
Katrina: I... I have a bit more color than him, hehe.
Tasha: 嗯他说可以开门了他说可以开门了
Tasha: Hmm, he said we can open the door now. He said we can open the door now.
Lucia: 啊也在叠被子中
Lucia: Ah, still folding the quilt.
Jake:放弃了
Jake: Gave up.
其他人：哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Lucia: 赛博朋克吗风
Lucia: Cyberpunk style, huh?
其他人：你怎么又把郁金香放卧室啊
Others: Why did you put tulips in the bedroom again?
其他人：真花假花
Others: Real or fake?
其他人：这个很好啊
Others: This is great!
Shure: 真花不行是吧
Shure: Real flowers aren't okay, right?
其他人：这竟然是个麻将桌
Others: It's actually a mahjong table.
其他人： 它不能放卧室
Others: It can't be in the bedroom.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这个
Lucia: Hahaha this...
Jake:这个大家可以想象的到
Jake: Everyone can imagine this.
Jake:我们平时的工作状态
Jake: Our usual work state.
其他人：开窗了吗
Others: Did you open the window?
其他人：没有那个没事
Others: No, that one's fine.
其他人：这个有事
Others: This one's not.
Shure: 哪个啊那是假的这是假
Shure: Which one? That one's fake. This one's fake.
其他人：没有睡过三个睡过两个人
Others: No, three people haven't slept over, two have.
Lucia: 你确定你不是一只手关掉8台电脑
Lucia: Are you sure you didn't turn off 8 computers with one hand?
其他人：哈哈哈是这么控制啊
Others: Hahaha, that's how you control it, huh?
Lucia: 哈哈你再说一遍
Lucia: Haha, say that again.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
其他人：哈哈就一只手碰掉总电源呗
Others: Haha, just one hand to turn off the main power.
Katrina: 按掉总电源
Katrina: Push the main power off.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Lucia: 然后他紧急把我叫出来帮他关硬盘
Lucia: Then he urgently called me out to help him turn off the hard drives.
Jake:有一次我不小心碰到这个键我按了下去
Jake: There was one time I accidentally hit this button and I pressed it down.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahahahahahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure: 插排的那个键
Shure: The button on the power strip.
Jake:把所有的都关掉然后我在松手离开
Jake: Turned everything off and then I let go and left.
Lucia: 我觉得这个故事特别精彩
Lucia: I think this story is amazing.
Lucia: 一定要讲给大家都听听
Lucia: Everyone has to hear it.
Lucia: 今天终于有机会了
Lucia: Finally got the chance today.
Katrina: 他就一直摁着不敢松吗
Katrina: Did he keep pressing it and didn't dare to let go?
Lucia: 对他一直摁着
Lucia: Yeah, he kept pressing it.
其他人：松了就完蛋了
Others: If you loosen it, it’s over.
Lucia: 摁到所有的硬盘都弹出之后他才敢挂
Lucia: He only dares to hang up after ejecting all the hard drives.
Katrina: 打仗踩到地雷
Katrina: 不客气
Katrina: You're welcome.
Lucia: 笑死我了
Lucia: That's so funny.
其他人：特产的石头
Others: Special local stones.
Lucia: 啊对对对
Lucia: Ah, yeah, yeah.
其他人：最长的这两个
Others: The longest two.
其他人：其他的都是随便配的
Others: The rest are randomly matched.
Shure: 哦那个芍药呢
Shure: Oh, what about the peony?
其他人：他一直没发货啊
Others: It hasn’t been shipped yet.
Shure: 这套好像要等花季之后哦
Shure: This set seems to come after the flowering season.
Shure: 我以为你忘取了
Shure: I thought you forgot to pick it up.
其他人：纸杯蛋糕
Others: Cupcakes.
其他人：那不至于
Others: That’s unlikely.
其他人：那卖不出去的
Others: Those won’t sell.
Katrina: 那边还放一条乱七八糟
Katrina: There's a mess over there.
Shure: rose
Shure: Rose.
Jake:我们今晚有4个人要
Jake: We have four people tonight.
Shure: r没有
Shure: No R.
其他人：这还不够吧
Others: That’s not enough, right?
Jake:是吧我平常都是这么睡的
Jake: Right? This is how I usually sleep.
Lucia: 没掉就很奇怪
Lucia: It's strange it didn’t drop.
Lucia: 我经常点开他都会掉线
Lucia: It often disconnects when I click on it.
Jake:最后把眼镜交上来吧
Jake: Finally, hand over the glasses.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure: complete
Shure: Complete.
Lucia: 他这现在这个这个
Lucia: Now he, this, this...